hi there welcome to this brand new
learning video called cloud computing
tutorial i'm samuel a multi-platform
cloud architect and trainer working for
simply learn let's dive deep into the
topics we're going to discuss here why
we needed cloud computing to begin with
and what is cloud computing and
different types of cloud computings
available at the moment and we also are
going to talk about a dominant cloud
providers available in the market at the
moment and we will touch a few topics or
scenarios on life cycle of a cloud
computing solution and we will be
talking about how cloud computing is
implemented in aws and there is nothing
like visually seeing how things work in
the cloud right so we're going to end it
with a demo and we're going to talk
about products or we're actually going
to use products like ec2 and s3 ec2
being a virtual computer in the cloud
and s3 being an object storage in the
cloud let's understand about why cloud
computing was needed what was the
problem that we had that cloud computing
solved and since then it took over the
market let's understand that first and
that will solve a lot of unanswered
questions about cloud computing or
services that you might have here on the
left we have an owner of a business and
he wants to set up an dc or have an i.t
infrastructure for his company so he
called paul an i.t educated person in
his company and consulted him about how
to go about setting up an id
infrastructure now paul is the kind of
guy who keeps himself updated about
what's happening in the iit industry and
he frequently goes through learnings
about the reason technology so without
missing a beat paul suggested why not
set up the environment in the cloud but
his manager was not sure about what is
cloud and and more than trying to
understand what cloud is he was curious
about the benefits of cloud over having
and dc locally so paul started to
explain the very same thing i'm going to
explain to you now let's start with the
expenditure or the billing model with
cloud the billing model is pay as you go
type meaning we use less and pay less
and we use more and we pay less per unit
on the other hand in on premises we
can't expect that we pay everything
upfront and there is an additional
operating cost and it never lets us to
dynamically scale in premises a lot of
space is required for seating the
servers but in the cloud not such space
requirement is needed for the
organization in on-premises we also need
a dedicated team to manage the hardware
and software but in the cloud no such
dedicated team is needed for most of the
services they all get managed by the
provider and even if we need to manage
them the provider gives us options to
manage them through the console which is
lot lot simpler than managing directly
from the device in the on premises we
need to admit the fact that data
security is poor due to the cost
involved in procuring the hardware and
software to provide the security but in
the cloud the security standards are
high due to the investments the
providers have done to secure the data
and to meet the compliance in
traditional dc there will generally be
less focus on data recovery and we kind
of settle for less when it comes to data
recovery due to the cost involved and
you know the effort involved in
replicating the data and even if we set
up a high performing data replication a
lot more can be done in the cloud for
the same cost the on-premises
environment lacks the flexibility needed
today like if i need to restructure the
it for the new age business needs then
the on-premises is not so friendly for
such changes but in the cloud i can
easily undo or tear down an environment
or migrate to the new environment and
tear down the old environment in few
button clicks now looking at the number
and the frequency of the releases that
happen scheduling updates would be an
full-time job but with cloud the updates
happen automatically in on-premises if
i'm working with the team that is spread
across the globe working with them in
unison and sharing the data is a tedious
work but with the cloud there are a lot
of tools and technologies put together
that makes it easy to share the data
with other members in the team or with
the new prospective customer in on
premises if i'm working with the team
that is spread across the globe working
with them in unison and sharing the data
is a tedious work but with a cloud there
are a lot of tools and technologies put
together that makes it easy to share the
data with other members in the team or
with a new prospect customer i will be
working with who is present across the
other side of the globe in on premises
the data will be present inside the dc
or inside the on-premises dc and even a
valid user trying to access the data
from outside the organization is a tough
task but with a cloud as long as someone
has internet providing the person access
is just a few mouse clicks away talk
about implementation building an
on-premises dc takes time i was working
on a project few years back and the goal
to make a dc go live at that time was
after two years from the date we were
speaking about it but with the cloud we
can bring our dc in the cloud within
weeks after all this explanation and
comparisons and talking about benefits
paul's manager was fully enlightened and
wants to have his iet environment in the
cloud but our paul is not done yet and
he took his manager through another
level of discussion about the cloud just
like i'm going to take you now so let's
talk about what is cloud computing now
cloud computing is the ability to
deliver on-demand computing service over
the internet and that too on a
pay-as-you-go basis now you might think
well what does that mean let me explain
now with cloud rather than managing
files on local storage devices cloud
computing makes it possible to save them
over the internet and access them from
the internet so i can be a mobile person
and i'm moving from place to place but i
can access the storage from the internet
because it's in the internet and if i
want to give access to somebody else
again it's easy for me to give access to
them as long as they have internet
connection available with them now let's
move further and talk about or get
understanding on the types of cloud
computing we can categorize the
different types of cloud computing based
on two wide categories one being a
deployment model and the other one being
service model let's talk about the
deployment model first deployment model
is categorized into three types first
one is public and then private and then
hybrid cloud in other words public cloud
private cloud and hybrid cloud it'll be
easy for me to explain and also it'll be
easy for you to understand if i walk you
through this example consider the
different types of vehicles we use to
commute from one place to another for
example if i want to travel i can pick a
bus which is accessible to anyone i get
in and i pay for the seat that i occupy
and i pay for the time that i will be
traveling in it and i'm done cost is
very less here a similar kind of thing
happens in the public cloud i pay only
for the resource that i use and i pay
for how long i use it if i use less i
pay less if i use more i pay more for
that month simple on the other hand
private cloud is like buying your own
car and using it for commuting purpose
here i pay a huge amount upfront and it
is all owned only by me i do not pay for
it in an hourly fashion but completely
and all up front the cost here is very
huge and thirdly if i want the best of
both types like the comfort of the own
car and still don't want to pay all
upfront otherwise one only to pay for
the time that i use the service i can
rent a car similarly i can have it in a
hybrid environment meaning if i already
have a dc i can integrate it with the
cloud and use both the dc's and that
would become an hybrid environment all
right so that was good often
learning let's summarize the types of
cloud based on deployment models and as
we know now about the public cloud
public cloud is an cloud infrastructure
that's made available to the general
public over the internet and it is owned
by the cloud provider some of the major
players as cloud providers are aws
microsoft azure ibm's blue cloud and sun
cloud and private cloud now this cloud
infrastructure is exclusively operated
by a single organization it can be
managed by organizations or third party
and may exist on premises or
off-premises doesn't matter but the
point here is this is exclusively
operated for a single organization and
some companies that provide private
cloud are aws and vmware and hybrid
cloud gives the best of both public and
the private cloud for example the
federal agencies they opt for private
clouds for storing and developing
personal data and they use public cloud
to share the non-sensitive data with the
general public or with other government
departments now let's talk about
different clouds based on the service
model if we need to categorize them
broadly we can categorize them as
infrastructure as a service ias or
platform as a service paas or software
as a service sas they sometimes are
referred to as i as pass and says now at
this moment you could be like this guy
thinking sam i thought you're done
categorizing the cloud now you're going
to talk about three more categories
which one should i pick well let me
explain if all that you want is just in
vm and you have all the expertise to
install the software on top of it and
make it work then go for is if you only
want a platform or an interface to
program or an interface to upload a
program and make it run then pick pass
or if all that you want is a finished
product hosted in the cloud and be able
to access it through the internet then
go for sas here you get a username and
password for an application and you can
begin to customize the application based
on your needs all right let's talk about
is in a bit more detail is it gives
basic computing infra it's based on pay
for what you use model and some of the
cloud providers who are big players are
aws azure and google and here the users
generally will be id admins in pass the
provider gives you a platform or a
runtime environment for developing
testing and managing application it's
platform ready you buy the platform you
upload your code and you start working
on it and it allows the software
developers to deploy applications
without running the underlying
infrastructure and as you might have
guessed by now the interesting
candidates who would use paz is software
developers and in sas everything is
managed by the vendor be it the hardware
or the software it's managed by the
vendor and we pay for the service and we
pay for it through a pay as you go
subscription model and as you might have
guessed the end users here would be end
customer itself all right let's put
together everything in the same page and
compare and contrast the different types
of service models in this chart it
explains the difference between the four
models starting from on-premises to i as
and then pass and says it is
self-explanatory that the resources
managed by us are huge in on-premises
and little less in is and further less
or reduced in pass and nothing to manage
when it comes to sas let me also explain
the different types of cloud services
through an example like this let's say
that you have a crush on cake and you're
planning to bake one yourself now let's
look at the options you can have you can
make all the ingredients yourself be the
floor butter and you know put together
and bake the whole thing yourself using
your own oven pan you know the needed
water and the rest you get idea right
everything is yours and that's on
premises all that you use is owned by
you and nothing is managed by the vendor
the other options you can have is buy
the ingredients and
mix and bake the cake yourself now this
would be like is here the infra is
managed by the provider and we get to
use it and customize it the way we want
it here the cloud service is in shared
responsibility the other options you
still have on hand is simply pick a
phone and order a cake now this is a lot
simpler than the rest we discussed so
far you know it's simply picking the
phone and ordering the cake and pay for
it when it arrives simple and when it
reaches home you will have to arrange
the table garnish the cake if that's
needed and then enjoy the cake it's the
same way with pass just get the platform
in which you would run your code and
upload your code and start running your
application here you and the vendor
still share the responsibility you still
have one more option left that is simply
go out and dine this is a lot lot
simpler that it requires no effort from
us at all you buy the fully finished and
garnished cake and pay for it and walk
out no responsibility on making the cake
it's the same way with sas we buy the
finished product and pay for the
finished application as next thing let's
talk about the different cloud providers
amazon web services aws is a cloud
computing service provided by amazon it
provides a mix of infrastructure as a
service is platform as a service pass
and package software as a service called
sas offerings microsoft azure formerly
known as windows assure is a cloud
computing service by microsoft and it
sort of specializes in using cloud for
building testing deploying and managing
the applications through the servers
throughout the global network that
microsoft manages it also provides
software as a service platform as a
service infrastructure as a service and
it supports lots of different
programming languages and tools and
frameworks including both microsoft and
third-party software and systems ibm
cloud is a cloud computing service
offered by ibm ibm cloud includes
infrastructure as a service software as
a service platform as a service now the
difference is here it offers through
public private and hybrid cloud delivery
models vmware on the other hand is an
subsidiary of dell technologies and
provides cloud computing and platform
virtualization software and services it
was the first commercially successful
company to virtualize the x86
architecture google cloud platform on
the other hand is offered by google it's
a suit of cloud computing services that
run on the same infrastructure that
google uses internally for its end user
products such as the google search and
the youtube you're familiar with
alongside a set of managed tools it also
provides cloud services including
computing services data storage services
data analytics and machine learning
services digitalocean on the other hand
is headquartered in new york city with
data centers worldwide digitalocean
provides developers cloud services that
help to deploy and scale applications
that run simultaneously on multiple
computers as of january 2018
digitalocean was the third largest
hosting company in the world in terms of
web phasing computers let's talk about
cloud computing in aws amazon web
services aws is an cloud computing
service provided by amazon and these
services are accessible over the
internet and because aws provides
infrastructure as a service it's a
flagship offering we can create and
deploy any type of application in the
cloud on top of the is that amazon
provides and you know the best part here
is the subscriptions are pay as you go
type you use less and pay less and only
for what you have used you use more pay
more but still less per unit for the
service used attractive isn't it now
let's talk about the life cycle of the
cloud computing solution the very first
thing in the life cycle of a solution or
a cloud solution is to get a proper
understanding of the requirement i
didn't say get the requirement but said
get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
servers that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound understanding
of the requirement helps in picking the
right hardware one size does not fit all
there are different services and
hardwares for different needs you might
have like ec2 if you're looking for is
and lambda if you're looking for
serverless computing and ecs that
provides containerized service so there
are a lot of hardware's available pick
the right hardware that suits your
requirement the third thing is to define
the storage choose the appropriate
storage service where you can backup
your data and a separate storage service
where you can archive your data locally
within the cloud or from the internet
and choose the appropriate storage there
is one separately for backup called s3
and there is one separately for archival
that's for glaciers so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
define the network define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications define and identify the
network services properly for example
vpc for network route 53 for dns and
direct connection for private p2p line
from your office to the aws data center
set up the right security services im
for authentication and authorization and
kms for data encryption at rest so there
are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are a
variety of deployment and automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example cloud watch is for
monitoring auto scaling is for being
elastic and cloud formation is define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your aws resources
and are the custom applications running
on aws platform there are variety of
deployment automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like cloud watch
for monitoring auto scaling for
automation and the cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build test and
deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done pick the
analytic service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
services where we can start querying the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick antenna
and other tools for analytics are emr
and which is elastic mapreduce and cloud
search all right enough of theory and
let's have a quick look at how two
services in aws ec2 and s3 work together
and benefits us here are two id
professionals talking to each other one
says i have an application which takes a
lot of storage and works only on linux
system which i do not have at the moment
and the other one is a smart guy and he
immediately replies that he could use s3
to store data and the tribe data and use
ec2 for all his compute needs and then
the curious conversation builds up and
the first person wants to know what is
easy to ns3 and the second guy starts to
explain that aws ec2 is a web service
that provides a secure and resizable
compute capacity in the cloud and ec2 it
can also be used to launch as many
virtual servers as we need and about s3
he explains aws s3 is a simple storage
service provided by aws and about s3 he
explains further saying that using
amazon s3 we can store android drive any
amount of data at any time on the web
all right so the very first thing is to
have an aws account so create an aws
account and second thing is to create an
aws s3 bucket and upload the files there
you know the files that ec2 server is
going to pull from will get stored in s3
as first thing all right so the first
thing is to create an s3 bucket so let's
create an s3 bucket and let's call it as
website bucket and these names will have
to be unique so let's see if this bucket
name is available says bucket name
already taken or already exist so let me
top it up with sl meaning simply learn
alright so we were able to create a
bucket and in that bucket let me upload
a content that basically is going to be
my index file that's going to go and sit
in my web server so let me also make it
public and view it all right so this is
the content that i have stored in my s3
and this is the content i'm going to
push to my ec2 server right second step
create an aws s3 bucket and upload files
we're done with that third is to create
an ec2 instance that's in other words
create an virtual machine in the cloud
let's go and create it all right the
third thing is to create an ec2 instance
so let's create an ec2 instance it's
plain and it's very simple i'm going to
keep everything as defaults here all
right so i've launched an ec2 instance
as you see it's running i also have an
ip address public ip address here with
that i have logged into this ec2
instance and i'm in the folder slash war
slash www.html
and as you see there is nothing in there
at the moment and this server also has
apache installed in it as you can see
you know i browse to the ip address of
the ec2 instance and it's showing a page
which is the default apache page all
right if i had any files in this folder
and that would get shown as the web page
insert off the default page our task is
to save files in s3 and move them to the
ec2 instance so s3 is going to act as a
storage or a repository or a source code
control in this example all right so
let's do that all right the third step
is to create your ec2 instance and
that's what we have done and the ec2
instance has no files in it and the
fourth step is to synchronize the source
code bucket with the ec2 instance let's
do that the actual command to do that
would be aws s3 sync and then the name
of the bucket from which we're going to
pull the code and the folder in which
we're going to put the code or the data
all right so it has downloaded something
look at that and now if we go back to
the test page and do a refresh there you
go it's showing the page that it pulled
from s3 so here i can use s3 as the
source code control bucket and
any information that i put in there will
get reflected in ec2 instance once i do
a sync every day and that's how i use s3
as my storage for ec2 right finally we
were able to synchronize s3 bucket and
the ec2 instance and we were also able
to view the results in the web browser
of the ec2 instance the data was copied
from s3 to the ec2 instance and that we
were able to view from the web browser
all right so what did we learn we
learned about what is cloud computing
understood the basics of cloud computing
we understood about the types of cloud
computing based on deployment models and
service model and then we understood how
cloud computing is with aws you know how
aws is a cloud computing service
provider and the benefits of using aws
over other providers we also looked at
life cycle of the cloud computing
solution and finally we did a demo on
aws ec2 and s3 and we saw how ec2 is
dependent on s3 or how we can use s3 to
be dependent on ec2 and sort of act as
in storage for the computer instance i
really hope you enjoy this video i'll
meet you in the next video thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here